taiwan has for the first time directly
accused china
of blocking a deal with germany's
biontech vaccine developer
for covet 19 jabs biontech had
contracted with the chinese company for
soon
to develop its covet 19 vaccine for
mainland china hong kong macau and
taiwan
but taiwan laws block the import of any
vaccine from china
at a ruling party meeting on wednesday
taiwan president xinguen said
and i quote we were close to completing
the contract with the original german
plant
but because of china's intervention up
to now
there's been no way to complete it
now china has denied blocking vaccines
to taiwan and has offered to provide
them to the island
taiwan has millions of doses of vaccines
on order from astrazeneca and modena
so far only about one percent of
taiwan's population has received a
vaccination
now we contacted biontech for their
response to saying gwen's
statement about chinese intervention the
company had this to say
we do not provide information on any
potential or possible distribution of
our vaccine
our goal at biontec is to make the
vaccine available to as many people
worldwide
as possible dw correspondent william
yang
joined me from taipei with more on this
story william
what does taiwanese president saying
when mean when she says
chinese intervention has prevented
taiwan
from acquiring the biotech vaccine
so according to her taiwan has been
trying to
sign a contract with biontech in germany
directly
to get at least 5 million doses of the
cova vaccine that was also according to
the health minister's
revelation back in february but then
somehow when
both sides were ready to actually issue
the uh official
press release the biotech called a
suspension of the whole process and
according to chen and also thai today
china was the one that has been
interfering with the whole process
however they did not offer more details
about
how exactly did china try to intervene
or put pressure either on
tech or on taiwan but uh the other very
interesting thing that we need to take
in
mind is that there was actually an
exclusive distributor
for the greater china region for
biontech which is a chinese company
called fuson
in shanghai they have been openly saying
that they are
willing to provide the biontech vaccines
for taiwan but because of taiwan's laws
to ban imports of all chinese vaccines
that has not been able to happen yet
you talked about taiwan trying to
negotiate directly
with uh buy on tech and apparently they
were quite close to uh finishing that
deal before it was suspended
what exactly is the problem with that
given in um
keeping in mind that biontech appears to
have an exclusive distributor
for taiwan already
so supposedly under the original
agreement
between biontech and the chinese
distributor
the chinese distributor should be
responsible for
all the deals that's going to happen in
the greater china region and that
actually covers taiwan
but because of taiwan's very sensitive
political nature and the law that bans
all the imports of the chinese
manufactured
vaccines even if the technology is using
the biotech
technology which is why the taiwanese
government has been trying to directly
negotiate
the deal with biontech in germany itself
and that according to tying one herself
was the same way that taiwan was able to
reach the deal with astra denica and
also moderna
and these are the vaccines that are
scheduled or has already arrived in
taiwan
but somehow in the case of biontech
because of the chinese
distributor and the potential
involvement of
chinese government in this the taiwanese
government has made it really clear
that they are only going to from here
this point on negotiate directly with
the manufacturer or kovacs because
they want to avoid any legal or
political risks
where does that leave a taiwan's
vaccination program which has so far
just covered about
one percent of the population
right exactly so far the only existing
and available vaccine vaccine for
all taiwanese citizens is the
astrazeneca one and there's only about
uh 410 000 available so far
and taiwan has only vaccinated about
300 000 of its citizens so far
and there are still millions of people
waiting and because of the outbreak
the concern and the need for raising the
vaccination rate is really
putting a lot of pressure on the
government and uh the government
said yesterday and today that according
to the plan
there's going to be two million more
arriving by the end of june and also 10
million
vaccines be ready by the end of
august and that is also going to include
some of taiwan's own manufacturer
vaccine but there's still a lot of
questions about whether taiwan can
actually
reach the certain protection level
before the outbreak can be brought down
correspondent william yang in taipei
thank you very much for that